das tagesgespräch heute mit dietrich
schulze marmeling fußball historiker und
auch buchautor zum thema fußball ich
begrüße sie deutschland ist raus ich
habe eben gesagt verdient verloren was
sagen sie ja sicher in unterm strich
schon verdient verloren wobei man sagen
muss es ist schon eine knappe
angelegenheit hätte im winter diese
chance genutzt hätte das ding rein
gemacht also so klar war es nicht das
ist zwar eben halt fußball da wissen wir
dass wenige momente ein spiel
entscheiden können und man manchmal auch
sagt naja wer wird dieses und jenes
passiert hätte es auch anders ausgehen
können
die engländer haben ihre unglücksserie
durchbrochen ist dieser sieg ein
historischer ach das würde ich nicht
unbedingt sagen
die engländer sind schon seit einigen
jahren auf einem sehr guten weg auch
geschuldet eine reform ihrer
nachwuchsausbildung und ich traue ihnen
auch wenn du dich jetzt noch nicht so
überzeugt dass mit diesem turnier schon
etwas zu sicher auch nicht immer so dass
die beste mannschaft ein turnier gewinnt
das turnier ist antonia und gerne
meisterschaft und na ja historisch die
engländer werden wahrscheinlich zu sehen
ich denke es war einfach ein ganz
normales fußball-turnier spiel sehr
nüchterne analyse heute morgen
vielleicht auch noch mit leichter
katerstimmung sprechen wir über die ära
löw sie ist gestern zu ende gegangen 15
jahre war er nationaltrainer er ist
weltmeister geworden doch seitdem fehlen
die erfolge der abschied ist jetzt noch
sehr frisch man möchte heute er danke
sagen aber wie beurteilen sie seine
bilanz wenn das wichtigste haben wir
nachher löw sechs mal das halbfinale
eines großen turniers erreicht das ist
glaube ich international einmalig 2014
weltmeister zweimal wm dritter 2006 und
ich glaube hat einen fehler begangen er
hätte nach der em 2016 ich sage bewusst
2016 2018 zurücktreten sollen
als 2016 bei die letzte das letzte
turnier nach meiner einschätzung wo wir
einen kader besaßen der um den titel
wirklich ernsthaft mitspielen konnte das
war 218 nicht der fall und jetzt bei
diesem turnier natürlich auch nicht und
da hätte er vielleicht schnitt machen
sollen weil die probleme waren damals
schon evident und wurden von ihm auch
schon benannt die lägen zum teil eine
ausbildung und daran dass auch uns auch
bestehende positionen einfach die
spieler fehlen
die werden in der bundesliga von
akteuren aus den fußball schulen anderer
länder besetzt also dass wir gleich
gezeigt und gewesen und dann hat er sich
vielleicht ein bisschen überschätzt hat
gedacht ich kann den großen umbau noch
mal schaffen wie nach 2008 aber dafür
stehen ihm gleich die spieler zur
verfügung
sie sind fußball historiker wenn sie
sich in ein paar jahre in die zukunft
versetzen wollen können was denken sie
nie wird jogi löw erinnert werden
mit irgendwie bisschen abstand wird man
auch das positive sehen wozu neben
dieser sportlichen bilanz auch gehört
dass er in deutschen fußball informiert
hat von meiner philosophie her von einem
spiel stil her hat mit alten überlebten
tradition gebrochen
aktuell überwiegt aber eher das negative
das hat aber auch mit einer ganzen
fußball debatte zu tun die mittlerweile
extrem personalisierte ist es extrem
spaß macht leute an zu schießen
ich denke da an die raue see und was man
den letzten tagen über ihn lesen musste
und das ist einfach cool er ist jetzt
einfach zu sagen entweder weg jetzt wird
alles besser 2022 werden wir weltmeister
mit hansi flick bin ich eher skeptisch
über die probleme tiefer liegen ja also
aktuell glaube ich eher negativ für die
überwiegend mit etwas zeit um abstand
wird man es vielleicht anders sehen
sie haben jetzt gerade schon nach vorne
geschaut das wollen wir auch gemeinsam
machen mit hansi flick viel zeit hat er
ja nicht die nächsten turniere stehen an
ich würde aber gerne noch mal auf das
nachwuchs thema zurückkommen dass sie
eben auch angesprochen haben mit der u21
sind wir ja doch eher sehr erfolgreich
im moment oder nicht ja weil wir über
sitzen ein bisschen diese turniere das
ist richtig
ich denke stefan kuntz ist gelungen eine
wunderbare turnier mannschaft
zusammenzustellen über sich
hinausgewachsen ist
wie viele ist von diesen spielern
wirklich bild der a nationalmannschaft
schaffen da bin ich skeptisch und man
muss auch sehen dass einige länder auf
gute u 21 akteure verzichtet haben bei
diesem turnier eben mit blick auf die
europameisterschaft die waren schon bei
der a nationalmannschaft
und wenn ich das nur an turnieren messen
da muss ich erklären können warum
frankreich seit 2002 glaube ich kein
finale mehr in einer in einer u 21 em
erreicht hat aber gleichzeitig das
riesige potenzial an wunderbaren
spielern hat gut ich habe es auch
vergleicht bei diesem turnier bei der wm
2018 habe ich immer gesagt wenn
frankreich gestartet wer mit zwei
mannschaften anzutreten hätten wir das
finale frankreich gegen frankreich
also ich würde das in einer zur
überschätzung turniere sind turniere
nicht 2004 ist griechenland
europameister geworden fand ich
irgendwie fußball wettskandal war aber
so also ich würde da sehr vorsichtig
sein
wir haben jetzt gerade schon mal so ein
bisschen erörtert was haben sie flick
erwarten wird welcher mannschaft er
vorfindet was erwartet denn die
mannschaft mit hansi flick
also fliegt halt ich von vielen sehr
guten trainer sagte bayern münchen
bewiesen hätte auch als assistent von
jogi löw bewiesen
sehr gut auch im menschen management im
umgang mit den spielern die fußball
philosophie wird nicht so viel anders
sagen wie bei jogi löw das wissen die
spieler sie haben ja diese philosophie
gemeinsamen seinerzeit formuliert er
wird sicherlich hier und da was ändern
das ist klar ich denke es ist sicherlich
gut ist dass man frischer wind wieder
reinkommen nach 15 jahren ganz klar und
vor allem du bist wenn du drei jahre
erfolglos war es dann bist du auch
irgendwie als trainer verbraucht also
aber es wird sich glaube ich nicht so
furchtbar viel
zu ändern und er wird mit ähnlichen
problemen zu kämpfen haben wie jogi löw
zu kämpfen hat und ein problem ist dass
diese mannschaft jetzt bezogen auf 22
november dezember 22 an der jugend
bedarf ist mats hummels wird
beispielsweise 34 während des turniers
in katar groß ist dann glaube ich 32 933
neuer ist 36 dann wird sich also etwas
tun müssen der zeitraum dafür zur
verfügung steht ist begrenzt zumal ja
auch gleich wieder in diesen das problem
hatte löw ja auch nach 2018 er konnte
gleich wieder diesen pflicht spielmodus
rainer muss gleich wieder ergebnisse
liefern
und ja es wird jetzt wird schwierig
werden aber ich mache mir eigentlich gar
nicht so große sorgen wir werden uns was
die qualifikation anbelangt das wäre es
schon schaffen
dietrich schulze marmeling herzlichen
dank für diese analyse
es gilt wie immer rückwärts analysieren
vorwärts spielen wir werden es erleben
vielen dank ja danke schön